[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et pouf
alors pourquoi pourquoi être aussi
complexe et pourquoi me répondit d'un
ancien parce que l'histoire
la bonne vieille explications par
l'histoire
ma petite liliane c'est que à l'époque
nous nous disions que nous étions beaux
cheveux au vent
planqué du maillot tricolore sur donne
au jir et c'est ce qui est de nos
platines yade et nous avons perdu face
c'est à cette équipe toujours la même tu
peux mettre n'importe quelle équipe
devant elle c'est toujours les mêmes qui
gagnent en faire levy 1982 encore nous
étions beau avec nos uniformes bleu et
rouge
impériaux pierre de servir napoléon le
troisième du nom et nous nous sommes
fait massacrer encore une fois a
toujours parlé même les mêmes qui ont eu
la bonne idée de mettre des uniformes
couleurs bout les mieux pour évoluer
dans la boue pour éviter de se faire
repérer par les lignes ennemies on vous
raconte que des bons souvenirs là et
puis tu sais ils ont mozart haydn brahms
strauss wagner oui francité sur le r
wagner nous sommes en 2016 et j'entends
ici et là des conversations je sens
comme un tout petit
j'ai complexe d'infériorité ou petits et
voilà jean petit et lance au vin qui me
prend et en plus de ça je suis passionné
par les grands films les grands péplums
genre baigneurs avec charlton heston
gladiator avec russell crowe à trois
avec brad pitt reste concentré games of
thrones riz et donc je sors du
conservatoire où l'on étudie la musique
dite classique et je me trouve je
voudrais trouver pardon un sujet de
recherche qui concentrent embrase tout
mes passions du moment et je finis par
me tourner vers le théâtre avec musique
bien sûr une musique aux log 6 millions
et donc je fini par tomber sur le
festival de béziers surtout la première
partie entre 1898 et 1911 et ce qui
m'intrigue tout de suite c'est que à
l'époque c'était sur nos me le bail rock
français or by roth
ces bannières mais j'ai rien tout de
suite
avec du recul au fil des années je me
rends compte que c'était pas simplement
par patriotisme mais que c'était encore
plus profond que ça il me fallait un
exemple un exemple dont vous pourrez
suivre les intrigues
un exemple dont je pourrais m'inspirer
partager les mêmes préoccupations en
tant que jeunes artistes en herbe mais
un exemple de quoi et bien de réactions
françaises
j'assume mais pas au sens réactionnaire
au sens réactif et on y comprend les
artistes français à l'époque car wagner
c'est la grande star de l'opéra le grand
phénomène romantique et ce n'est pas
simplement un compositeur c'est
quelqu'un qui écrit de grands ouvrages
sur la musique sur l'art d'appel salars
de l'avenir justement c'est aussi
quelqu'un qui a eu le culot on peut le
dire de faire construire son propre
théâtre pour y faire jouer ses heures et
il a fait ça à byron dans une petite
ville bavaroise au nord de la franconie
et c'est très important
car tous les artistes français les
critiques de presse s'y rendent pour
faire ce qu'on appelle à l'époque un
véritable pèlerinage
voilà c'est ça réglait l'exemple que
j'ai choisie est aussi considérée comme
une décentralisation artistique et là il
faut que je vous dise à la grande
vieille tradition jacobine de la france
mesdames messieurs tout est dans la
capitale voilà c'est comme ça c'est ça
pas trop changé d'ailleurs chaque
institution à son propre répertoire
l'opéra c'est justement dans l'opéra
l'académie française c'est pour tout ce
qui est théâtre entièrement chanté
l'opéra comique c'est les dialogues
parlés avec en plus de chanter la
comédie française et le théâtre de
l'odéon c'est pour tous les grands
classiques corneille molière racine et
surtout on ne se mélange pas mais là ce
qui est très particulier avec le
festival de béziers et je pourrais aussi
citer les chorégies d'orange c'est que
l'initiative vient non pas de l'état
mais de personnes locales que ce soit
des mécènes des artistes et c'est ça qui
est extrêmement important
donc nous on fait parce qu'une fois
qu'on a dit qu'on voulait contrer wanner
ça ne suffit pas il ya tout à faire
comment on fait quand on est un mécène
en l'occurrence propriétaire viticole
qui s'appelle casse tête dont de vote et
que l'on veut créer son propre festival
dans sa ville natale il faut contacter
tous les artistes les auteurs les
compositeurs les costumiers le peintre
décorateur ça en fait toute une équipe
est-ce qu'on devient directeur de son
propre festival
est-ce qu'on organise des répétitions
comment on fait lorsque l'on est auteur
dramatique
il faut écrire une histoire mais
laquelle avec quel sujet des sujets
mythologiques des sujets historiques
est ce qu'on met une histoire d'amour
est-ce qu'on va parler de l'histoire de
la région biterroise
comment on fait lorsque l'on est
musicien on va devoir placer de la
musique est ce que l'on place beaucoup
de musique
ou pas mais attention faut pas que ce
soit mon père a il faut pas que tout
soit chantée est ce que l'on favorise
les coeurs les grandes masses vocale ou
est-ce que l'on laisse toute la place
aux grands virtuoses soliste toutes ces
questions auxquelles je vais devoir
répondre j'ai la chance de pouvoir avoir
ma disposition tout un tas de source
ils sont disposés un peu partout en
france donc notamment en ce qui concerne
les livres et dramatique
voilà que l'on peut trouver à la
bibliothèque de l'opéra de paris ou à la
bnf également mais aussi aux archives à
montpellier où je vais pouvoir trouver
donc l'histoire mais aussi la
distribution des tragédiens et voilà
d'autres informations mais aussi longue
que la musique donc des partitions de
musique que je vais devoir étudier donc
la mélodie le rythme mais aussi leur
kerstrat sion et ça donc il ya deux
types de musique on va trouver la
version piano chant très pratique pour
les chanteurs pour pouvoir répéter
facilement et donc la grande partition
port qu'être car c'est jouer en plein
air et pour ça on a besoin de beaucoup
d'instrumentistes mais à d'autres
sources également des iconographies
notamment les cartes postales donc c'est
très pratique parce que ce sont des gens
qui ont assisté à des répétitions ou
voire même aux créations des oeuvres et
kipré qui ont pris des photographies de
certaines scènes marquantes
donc ça c'est très précieux je pourrais
citer également les contrats de travail
des artistes et encore bien d'autres
éléments et aussi il faut pas que
j'oublie les d'être les correspondances
entre le mécène entre les artistes eux
mêmes
que faire avec toutes ces sources
eh bien il va falloir il va falloir que
je les compare donc j'ai parlé de byron
français et justement il faut que
j'essaye de voir comment les français se
distinguent
comment mieux les caractériser et donc
le grand chapeau méthodologique ça va
être de comparer des oeuvres françaises
avec wagner
mais attention ce n'est pas la seule
opération parce que justement je parlais
des lettres des correspondances on va
prendre une pièce il faut quand même que
je compare l'idéal qui a été verbalisé
dans ces documents avec des réalisations
concrètes que sont les oeuvres et
parfois il peut y avoir donc des
convergences est vrai mais parfois il
peut y avoir aussi des divergences ou
des tensions voire même des incohérences
et en tant que musicologue en tant que
chercheuse je dois aussi montrer ça et
je ne dois pas faire ceci seulement une
fois deux fois trois fois non je dois
faire ça à huit fois en fait j'ai huit
pièces que j'étudie dans mon corpus est
donc enfin tout ceci c'est à toi me
mener vers un projet non pas seulement à
visée scientifique mais à visée
artistique pour pouvoir produire
notamment ce qu'on appelle des livres
objets où vous allez pouvoir trouver
donc un cd avec l'enregistrement mais
aussi donc l'histoire sous forme de
livret est également des articles
scientifiques qui parle du contexte de
l'époque
les biographies des auteurs mais je
pense que ça peut être aussi un tremplin
donc pardon permettent donc à des
artistes voilà de remonter de recréer
ces pièces là et enfin j'y viens un
tremplin pour de nouvelles adaptations
cinématographiques
voilà manque ici une grande fan de
cinéma je pense que c'est vraiment
l'occasion car c'est des pièces qui
n'ont jamais été encore recréer et en
france on n'a pas tellement de genre
épique
alors oui je sais vous allez me parler
de vercingétorix à guichen l'envers je
sais je sais je sais je sais j'ai mis
mon mec on me jeanne d'arc avec luc
besson donc je pense que ça en vaut la
peine
je pense qu'en france on est capable de
faire ça alors voilà c'est un projet
assez long assez costaud et quelquefois
j'ai des petits coups de mou alors quand
c'est comme ça
j'aime bien prendre une pause jules
césarienne et je me dis une courte
devise que j'ai trouvé à une précédente
occasion je me dis avait cocorico je
vous assure c'est très motivant
voilà je vous remercie pour votre
attention donne confiance
[Musique]